Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast in now.
Just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on Ya.
How are Ya?
How's it going?
I'm actually doing great despite the,
uh,
that cough I just did.
There wasn't a real cough.
I just,
you know,
I've,
I've run out of unique ways to say I'm just checking in on you.
I try to do it a little bit differently and I,
I got nothing left.
I don't know what you want from me.
Um,
anyway,
so let's get on.
Let's get on with the podcast here.
You know,
this is just a quick one.
This isn't even an official podcast,
despite the fact that I have fucking advertising on it.
It's not an official one.
This is me just poking my head into a little office,
itchy,
a little cubicle and the living room.
If you're unemployed or maybe a,
you're living off a trust.
Yeah.
To go egg big shout out to anybody.
Just sitting around,
living off a trust,
you know,
what are you going to do today?
I go down to the art store and get yourself an Easel,
you know,
little canvas dot.
Payton.
That's what people do.
You know when you're like super fucking rich,
there's no reason for you to go outside.
There's just no fucking reason.
I,
I really can't stand when people judge,
you know,
trust fund babies.
I feel that's like one of the,
one of the biggest issues that this country is dealing with right now.
We see harsh judgment of trust fund babies,
you know,
I mean anybody can be fucking broke and be like,
look at that rich conscious sitting over there doing nothing.
What a waste.
What a waste of a fucking life.
You know?
Let me tell you that she was subway sandwich,
eating judgmental.
Fuck.
Let me ask you this.
If you were in that situation,
what would you be doing?
Cause I could tell you what I would be doing the exact same fucking thing and
all you fucking people on your high horse,
no.
Do what I could do it.
You know,
I'm one of those people,
you know,
people know that people know me.
I have to wake up with a purpose.
If I don't have a purpose in life,
shut the fuck up your bills.
All right?
That's what you're doing.
You're walking out the door and you chasing the fucking carrot and some someday
you're dreaming.
You dream the debt.
Carrots not going to be there.
You want to be that evil guy.
You know?
Look at George Bush,
man.
Do you ever see a guy enjoying not being president more than that guy?
He's actually good at what he does.
He's not a trust fund baby either,
by the way.
I'm just saying,
you know he's actually good at it.
Just sits there.
I wonder what he thinks about just there's no way to be present when you leave
as president.
You have dead bodies on your conscience or do you made the right decision or the
wrong decision?
At some point you had to shoot off some missiles because who's kidding?
Who America is the world's babysitter.
Okay.
We know what we know what's best for you,
okay?
And what is best for you is to do what we say and give us your natural resources
as we pretend to care about your people.
Okay?
It's like a lifetime movie.
Everybody's acting like something special's happening at the end of the day was
wasn't that really just a bunch of shit so you could fucking make money?
Isn't that what it was?
I have no idea what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about trust fund babies and I'm sick of the judgment of who judges a
baby.
First of all,
kind of a fucking person.
You maybe that's why God didn't give you money.
You have to think about that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's called Karma.
Isn't that the most overused working expression Karma?
This is my theory on Karma.
Karma Getcha unless you,
unless you don't give a fuck.
If you don't give a fuck and you,
if you truly don't give a shit,
you got to have like a level of guilt for common to come back and bite you in
the ass.
But if you just some fucking entitled con you,
those people,
they'd skate through life.
You know you have a,
him you haven't seen entitled can just walk across the room.
It's like he has those little kids shoes on.
Then have the wheels on them.
You only take two steps.
They just glide across the room.
They don't care about breaking hearts.
They don't care about evicting people.
Right.
They don't give a shit who fucking sewed their shirt together that out.
What does that endangered species throw it on the grill.
They don't care.
You know,
there's a genius to that.
Just not giving a shit.
You know what I mean?
I'd love to see one of those people,
you know,
in the afterlife,
if you have to get,
if you actually get judged just to see the fucking look in the face,
you know what I mean?
And then God at some point would have to feel some sort of shame being like,
well,
you know,
at the end of the day I assembled that.
You know what I mean?
That's why I've never understood about the judgment.
It's just like,
you know,
especially with these fucking sociopath's as opposed to the levelheaded saint
that I am,
these fucking,
these fucking sociopath's out there.
Like,
where does,
you know,
shouldn't you know,
shouldn't you be judging God on that one?
Gingy be looking up like really,
you know,
what are you doing blow last night?
Yeah.
You forgot to put the a I give a shit about other people assembly into this one.
Just fucking sent it out there.
I Dunno.
The more I,
I vaguely pay attention to all that space shit.
You know,
I hate people who are in this space by the way.
There was talking about do you understand and you can put,
it's like,
yes.
Yeah,
I get it.
You know,
ourselves.
Understand is we fucking,
we've,
we've seen how gigantic it is yet we haven't found anything.
So I still think this place is pretty amazing.
It's fascinating as Mars is,
this does nothing to do.
I don't understand these fucking people that want to go to Mars and live there
and it's like,
and do what?
Huh?
Live in some fucking strip mall for the rest of your life.
Some star trek looking strip mall.
Yeah.
Fucking drinking Tang.
Just so you can say,
Oh yeah,
you know,
that's your big fucking move.
The,
you know,
people want to live on Mars,
that means they suck at everything else in life.
Right?
They got enough of the,
you know,
you know what it is.
You graduate high school,
you want to come back someday,
right.
Smoking a big cigar
going,
hey,
you know,
yeah,
I was jacked guy used to push around the playground,
but you know what I did right?
I went to,
I did things,
I did digs and now I smoke this and I drive down and see that over there.
That's fucking me.
It makes it,
I matter.
So usually in this day and age,
that means you're going to try to create an APP,
right?
You gonna Fuck Fuckin,
I don't know,
get some sort of,
you start a website where you curate videos and fucking news.
I don't know what these fucking millennials do,
but I think if you,
if you suck at that,
right?
You can't play an instrument.
And you ego could not just handle,
just being happy with what you have.
I think at that point it's like I can't just go back to my high school reunion,
just be in some regular Joe Waking up in the morning,
putting my coffee and my thermos
going into the shower quietly crying was the water cascades over my face and my
wife comes walking in going to Uri.
Just be like,
yeah,
I just sneezed.
I'm fine.
Just washing my face.
Right.
I think at some point,
either you just fucking give in and just say,
hey man,
you know,
being a regular guy kind of fucking cool.
You know,
or you can't handle it right.
They should mind me.
I've never seen a few good men.
You get hurdle the truth,
you know,
there's too many,
too much gritten a teeth in that movie.
That's right.
Iceman.
I am dangerous,
right?
Too much of that shit.
So I never watched it.
You know,
which people walking around dressed in fucking then little navy suits.
Um,
anyways,
he can't fucking handle it.
And you gotta go back to high school,
you and you got to do something.
And I think at that point,
that's when you just say,
listen,
I,
I got to live on Mars.
I mean,
I can't go back with nothing.
I got to have something to say.
That's like Lance Bass.
He couldn't handle that.
Justin Timberlake walked away from,
from in sync.
Right.
Ah,
want it that way or whatever the fuck they sing that song where they all,
I all,
I could like puppets,
right?
He just fucking walked away,
you know,
and got the one guy,
the goatee guy,
he's got a sense of humor about himself.
He makes all these funny commercials.
He'll do a thing.
He doesn't give a fuck.
Right?
You've got the dreadlock guy.
Did he used to bang Jennifer Aniston or was that the other guy
who,
some white guy with dreadlocks used to go out with Jennifer Aniston,
you know,
have you one of those beautiful celebrities always dates a guy and he always
have that,
that,
that really,
you got that moment like,
wow,
why didn't I learn how to fight fucking play the Ukulele and wear flip flops?
That's what I had to do.
Fucking walking around with your goddamn man tits.
Um,
anyway,
sorry.
And I think lance can handle it.
He's just like,
what the fuck?
You know?
So then annexing,
you know,
he's signing up to go out and space to some,
I'll try and outdo.
Oh,
what'd you put you put out futures?
Sexy songs.
Huh?
Wait,
wait,
wait.
Right Wayne,
Wayne,
Wayne mad man.
I'm going to outer space.
What?
Oh,
what is it about wearing your pajamas in the middle of the day?
That just,
it just fucking opens your mind up.
You know what I mean?
I swear to God.
Okay.
There is no free of feeling that being a white male,
heterosexual still in your pajamas at 11 o'clock in the morning on a weekday,
on a weekday.
And you know what,
cause I'm a liberal because I want everyone to experience that,
you know,
all the people in the Philippines.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
I'm actually,
I'm in a good mood because I did something yesterday that scared the living shit
out of me and I didn't die,
which is all,
you know,
obviously,
cause I'm doing this podcast.
So,
you know,
I hadn't flown a helicopter,
uh,
since like October until this month.
And I flew for the first time and I could not believe how fucking rusty I was.
How much just shit.
You forget.
You're like,
what?
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
You know,
darn it.
Base,
turn it final.
I didn't even slow down.
I was so busy trying to keep the fucking pad between the compass,
you know,
and the Dashboard Day,
I can't remember what the fuck you call it,
the control panel that I forgot.
I was still doing like 65 knots and I'm woo.
I fucking went right by it.
I had to slam on the brakes.
Right.
So,
but you know,
I flew around,
shook,
shook off the Russia,
he's coming around,
you know.
So I went,
I went again yesterday and uh,
went up with my instructor and he was like,
so what do you want to do?
I said,
all right,
let's do the pattern.
Let's fly the traffic pattern.
Let's do some auto sets where they simulate a main road of failure.
That's the big fan above your head.
Like what if all of a sudden the engine cuts up,
you know,
um,
and then those kicks left.
What do you do?
You slam the collective down,
had right pedal,
right trim,
air speed,
rpm.
He'd come,
the rpms coming up,
you pull the collective up,
you catch fucking things,
you pick up your spot.
So we were doing those and at some point I was just like,
all right,
fuck this.
Okay.
Um,
I,
I have to fly this thing by myself or solo.
Is he saying the business?
But I'm just a novice.
So I said,
all right.
He goes,
well,
okay,
we did a couple of those.
He goes,
what do you want to do now?
I said,
all right,
can,
uh,
can you just step out and let me just fly this thing around one time by myself
just to do it again?
And he goes,
yeah,
absolutely.
So he steps out and up to that point,
it had been a great day.
You know,
not a lot of traffic over there.
Everything's fucking fine.
So he gets out,
roll it back up.
You know,
lights are out,
PM's are in the green gauges.
Real Green cabaret heats up.
I fucking lift up light on the skids,
bring it up,
bump,
holding a hover.
Here we go.
Cyclic.
Wait for it.
Less weight in the fucking thing.
You know,
fucking palms are sweating.
there's always said,
Don,
I can't believe I actually fucking know how to do this thing right.
So immediately there's a fucking crosswind.
So I'm looking at the wind sock.
God,
you fucking content.
Fight it.
Left pedal.
Now I'm facing the wind,
so everything's fine.
And next thing you know,
like fucking,
like three jet blue's are taken off at southwest is landing.
You know,
I made my call and the guy's like,
you know,
whatever.
Fucking six Victor Hotel.
Standby.
Standby means shut the fuck up.
I always forget that cause then I would go six tricks through hotel standing by.
So I'm fucking sitting there.
I'm,
I felt like I was in a oven for 20 minutes.
What I really wanted to have happen,
it was just like one of those things where it's like,
all right,
fuck this up,
fill in this rolled out,
have him step out.
I fucking roll back up,
lifted off.
As for clearance,
he gives it to me and I just take it for a lap around the airport.
That's all I wanted to do.
So now I'm fucking sitting in this Harvard just going,
Jesus Christ.
Now I'm thinking,
what the fuck am I doing?
So finally
he called,
yeah,
go fuck go.
Six Victor Hotel.
I left closed traffic.
I've cleared for takeoff,
cleared for takeoff,
six Victor Hotel.
And then I,
uh,
I fucking took off,
brought it around and when I was turned across,
when,
you know,
I'm looking for traffic,
did join the downwind,
make sure I don't have any problems.
I was actually thinking like,
you know,
last night I did stand up dressed is Steven Adler at the goddamn comedy jam.
I tried out a new fucking bit about blow up dolls that was killing so hard.
I looked over and Josh,
Adam Meyers was fucking dying,
laughing on the side of the stage.
And so as much as you make people laugh,
when you look over and you see a fellow comedian dying laughing,
you know,
you're onto something.
So then I went back and I got to play Ryan Sore,
dressed as Steven Adler sound,
the sound guy.
Now I would have dressed up as Matt camera,
but he's just,
you know,
he doesn't have any unique facial hair.
He's got that sorted out.
Luke Skywalker haircut.
I just want to look like me with the stupid wig on,
you know.
Um,
and then I got to play the encore paradise city and I was thinking,
I fucking did that.
I did stand up and play drums live last night.
It right now I'm flying a helicopter by myself
and I flunked so much shit in high school,
terrible at math,
fucking flood French.
All of that shit
was a great feeling.
And I was like,
Oh yeah,
that's right.
I'm flying a helicopter so I get to the downward,
you know,
where did you go?
Across three zero.
You bring your fucking carburetor heat up.
See if you're fucking carburetor.
Doesn't freeze over in the engine,
doesn't cut out as you slowing down.
Came around,
still pulling power kit,
my 60 knots as I turned the fucking base in the file.
K right in lead,
set that thing down nicely.
And uh,
they're,
my instructor came back in and just,
you know,
plugs his headphones in.
He goes,
he goes,
uh,
how did that feel?
I said,
I,
you know,
I said it was like riding a bike except you could kill you
self.
I started laughing and what I've found with instructors is they're all bad ass
guys.
Every one of them chicks,
they're all fucking bad assets,
you know.
But the second you admit that you're actually scared,
they always laugh.
And then they usually tell you a story how fucking nervous that they were.
But if you have some fucking cocky cunt,
um,
you don't want to do that,
cause then what they're gonna do is they're going to chop throttle on you as you
fucking doing some stay here.
And I don't need that.
Even though it's good training.
I've never had anybody do that to me.
Um,
but anyways,
so I did it and it made me feel
fucking amazing,
man.
She's like the sickest goddamn feeling and I sweat it.
God,
all I need to do is make like another $40 million and I think I could actually
afford to truly engage in that hobby.
I in La,
it's just super expensive.
I think if you live more in the middle of nowhere,
the big fucking thing is like just storing the goddamn whatever you get the
plane or the helicopter.
Um,
I dunno if anybody knows like a cheap way to do it,
I would absolutely,
uh,
absolutely do it.
But until then,
I'm just treating it like the way I treat cars.
Like I just go on the road,
you know,
I go to budget and then that's it.
I just,
whatever fucking car they give me,
I get it.
And I gotta be honest with you.
I,
that's the one thing that bugs me about renting helicopters at every time you
fucking go in there,
eh,
something's a little different,
you know,
just be nice to know you fucking tail number.
Not have to fucking constantly be looking or the control panel,
nowhere everything is.
Know how everything works.
Every radio seems to be a little bit different.
It's just like a fucking,
it's just that extra thing you got to like deal with it.
I wish,
um,
I didn't and I'd love to just buy one of those fucking are 20 twos,
you know,
they're fun is held.
They just a little to cdot,
right?
Any,
you're really flying it.
It's like if you had a car that just had drum brakes and no power steering,
like you really fucking,
you know,
are holding up.
This is just what I've heard from other pilots.
Cause I've never flown anything fancy,
nothing fancy.
Like,
um,
but I really fucking enjoyed it.
And,
uh,
just even doing that,
I mean that's how long it takes to fly the pattern.
Um,
yeah,
I mean that couldn't have been more than like felt like 90 seconds.
You'd probably,
maybe it was a little bit longer.
I don't know.
But uh,
yeah,
I dunno.
It's just fucking definitely left the place yesterday.
You know,
that's one of those things where you'd get did something great and you're
driving away and you've got the window down just driving right.
Gone.
So anyways,
you guys been watching the playoffs?
Yeah,
I'd say for first round playoffs.
I'll tell you the series I'm watching obviously,
and I'll say,
I'll tell you again,
I'm just going to keep saying,
I'll tell you,
I'll tell you I'm watching those Celtics and the Bulls,
um,
Celtics are now up three games to two after being down.
Oh,
too.
After looking like we had no fucking answers.
Right.
And,
uh,
which is why my nod for MVP of the series is Rondo without a doubt.
Because the second he went down the series just completely changed.
MMM.
And I thought all of the Bulls had this figured out,
but evidently it was rando he knew what the fuck was going on.
I'm giving them full fucking credit because it's just,
it's been a tale of two cities.
You know,
they looked like they were going to sweep us and now it looks like we're going
to run the table on them.
However,
however,
I think Rhonda is coming back.
He took his cast off,
his suits have long sleeves again and um,
I can't wait to watch games.
Six I want to see like is this guy is good is it appears in this,
in this series at last night,
admittedly the officiating was a little subpar and it definitely went in the
Celtics favor and I loved with Lopez was applauding the fucking refs.
Sometimes it's worth getting a fucking technical.
I love that guy,
man.
That guy comes out every night,
wants to play.
He's a little fucking weird.
He's on his own vibe.
He just,
I,
I really liked that guy.
I love when he fucking started clapping.
It's like my favorite thing and then they go to,
I think it actually work because then we went down,
they called the ticky tack fall on the other end and you saw Dwayne Wade was
whatever the Celtic said to him.
I think it might've been uh,
Isaiah,
he just started smiling and laughing.
I swear to God,
man.
I just think the NBA is so fucking controlled.
Okay.
I really do.
Just for the simple fact that you can do it.
I've said this a zillion times,
there is no easier game to control or fix than basketball cause it's the only
fucking game where you can sit down as a ref.
You can take people out of the game,
you know?
I mean,
I guess all the games you can object somebody,
but they,
you know,
in baseball,
football,
hockey,
you really have to do something.
You just can't point at a guy and be like,
hey,
go sit on the fucking bench.
Well I guess you can in hockey,
right?
Yeah,
I dunno.
You know what,
that's one of those things where you think you have a good theory and then you
fucking explore all the options you like,
oh well maybe it doesn't work.
Whatever.
No,
but you only sit them down for like fucking two minutes and they come back out
and it's not like,
well fucking Wayne Gretzky's got three penalties two more and he's out of the
game right?
There you go.
Gone back on track with my theory.
You can't sit Tom Brady down all you got like this is what kills me about
basketball.
I don't give a fuck how many points you're up.
You're up like 20 points.
You just like,
yeah,
this game's a rep is one quarter ago.
You know,
most teams are lucky if they score like 27 and a quarter,
that's like a fucking great quarter.
We're up by 20 all we really need to do is score eight points and we're fine.
And the next thing you know it's just like a little fucking jerk offs are on a
27 to run every fucking time.
That whole thing.
It's a game of runs.
I don't think it is.
I think it's a game of fucking ratings in.
If a team gets up too high,
they just start fucking call,
call and files together.
Ah,
that's stupid.
That's a stupid fucking theory.
But it does,
it just appears that way.
Maybe it is the nature of the game that nobody can just blow somebody out.
They always come back.
Yeah.
Like I would say like 85% of the time,
of course I didn't do any research,
but you seem to 85% of the time you fucking go,
you go up by 30 points in the first half,
you know,
somehow by the end of the game of what away,
what else?
Sex,
what are the most unbelievable and probable come back
since last night's fucking slew of NBA Games that did the exact same thing.
Yeah.
Um,
anyways,
I don't want to talk about it.
All I'm saying is that I think a
Rondo really showed,
I mean just,
I mean it's fucking unbelievable.
Like how much the series change.
One guy is gone and the whole thing turns around.
Um,
so I'm excited to watch games six.
I mean,
I like seeing greatness.
I don't give a shit.
I mean,
I hope it's on my team,
but if it isn't that can't and I'm like,
I can't just sit back and appreciate it.
Right.
I tried to be a good guy for right now.
I don't know why I have this fucking,
this pillow that wraps around you,
this little half circle pillow.
You know when you have a baby abuse,
it's perfectly set him down.
You give him that bottle of Jack,
you know,
and then that's it.
You know?
But if you try to do it with regular pills,
it doesn't work.
But for some reason I have it around me right now.
I don't know.
It feels right.
Like I don't wait to have a kid that buy one of these fucking semicircle
pillows.
Um,
all right.
What else did I want to talk about?
I've been watching,
you know,
I've been watching the hockey.
Okay.
Gotten over the fact that my Bruins had been knocked out by the quietest fan
based team in the league.
Right.
The team that cheering forgot until April.
Then all of a sudden they all show up like they give a shit.
Oh man,
that was fucking hard watching that.
Anyways,
um,
the prejudice are looking great,
but I still think a,
I don't even if I already talked about this,
I started this podcast twice.
I forget if I brought this shit up.
I still,
I'm still going with the penguins.
I think the penguins repeat.
Um,
and I Miss Anaheim Edmonton.
I bet that's a great fucking series too.
It's so crazy.
They're already down to just two series in each conference,
so I have to make sure that I'm watching,
um,
for those people last week you're like,
hey,
how come you didn't talk about Moto GP,
the race in Austin?
You know what?
I didn't see it.
And uh,
then I,
I realized I recorded it and this is what you learn.
If you're new to moto GP and you go to record the race and you've got to fucking
do it.
It might,
it might be better than Formula One just because of the sheer amount of like
passing in lead changes and all that.
It's fucking insane.
And then the fact he just watched these guys falling off motorcycles.
I wrote one of the races.
Um,
well let me explain it first.
You're going to go to record it.
If you novice like me,
you go to record it and you'll be watching like the first race in it.
Oh,
say Moto too.
When they're on these little skinny bicycle tires and you're like,
those don't look like the fucking,
you know,
those Badass bikes that I saw.
What's going on here?
Then there's moto three and you're like,
where does the real one?
Was that Ross,
Valentino Rossi guy,
whatever the fuck his name is.
Uh,
Mike and the mechanics,
whatever that other guy's name is.
I don't know any of the fucking name shed.
So there's three different classes.
This is what I learnt.
All right.
On Moto GP as they say.
And um,
there's Modo too.
There's Modo three and there's moto GP and that's basically like being in Aa Aaa
and then being in the majors.
Now for whatever reason,
modal three is the lowest level.
So I guess they go in three,
two,
one.
I guess that's how they do it.
And they don't say one,
they just say GP,
which I believe stands for Grand Prix.
I don't fucking know.
So motor three is 250 cc according to this,
this thing on reddit here to 250 cc bike,
you know,
so that's basically a cubic centimeters.
So it's a smaller engine.
It's not as fast.
You know,
it's still fast as shit the way they're doing it.
But you know,
that's the one like,
okay,
all right there grasshopper,
we'll,
you know,
we'll see how he'd do it this level.
And then if you,
uh,
succeed at that level,
then they move you up to moto two,
which is 600 CC's.
Evidentaly four strokes and all the engines are made by Honda,
which I find interesting.
Um,
so hot,
they're all Honda base.
Everybody's working the exact same shit.
That's probably so they can truly get an idea of who,
um,
who is the best writer,
who's going to get called up to the show moto GP.
And according to this person,
a lot of times in Modo,
Modo to the race is better because they all just have basically the exact same
engine.
So this guy was saying you could throw,
you usually can throw a blanket over the top three people in that race.
Um,
and then the big show is moto GP,
which is a thousand CC's.
Um,
and those things are just fucking rockets.
And I watched his whole thing on how they build them.
They're hand handbuilt gets how much those motorcycles cost a piece.
Take a wild guess.
Like if for some reason you went down and they said,
hey,
you want to take it for a lap,
but if you fucking trashed this thing,
you've got to pay for it.
Okay.
And they give you that fucking suit with the airbag.
And unfortunately you don't,
high side East slide off the bike and you get up and be like a shit.
What's that?
Gonna cost me?
I would have thought anywhere between 102 hundred 50 grand,
you know,
and I understand that it's a fucking racing bike and all that,
but you know,
they're a little last things.
You know what I mean?
You got to do a build on a car.
There's like fucking people working on it on the other side.
He can't even see him a motorcycle.
I mean it's,
it's right there.
Everything is right fucking there.
You and another guy can lift up the engine and the shit is small.
It does like 100 a hundred to 250 grand is what I would've guessed.
Three 75 tops.
Right.
This is like,
I'm at the showcase showdown on the prices.
Right.
And I horrifically underbid is what happens.
Those bikes cost $2 million each,
$2 million each.
They're handmade.
Um,
all this space age stuff.
I watched this whole thing on how they build them.
The gas tank is actually underneath the seat.
What's where the gas tank usually is,
is the fuel injector.
There's an airport right in front of that,
right where the fucking front late.
Usually I just went on,
I watched the whole goddamn thing was absolutely fascinating and a,
I'm totally in on that sport watching that sport.
And I'm watching the F one.
I don't know when the wrote next races,
but uh,
if you want to watch dude,
well I think it was the motto to race.
The last one,
this fucking guy came out of a turn is backend started fishtailing and he went
like right up and over the handlebars doing,
I don't know how fast,
I don't,
I don't get how they get up
cause he,
he landed on like his foot,
he limped for a second and then he just kinda just shakes it off.
They're like,
hey,
said foot problems,
said foot problems in the past.
I'd imagine he'd had everything problems.
You fall off a bike.
You know,
it's funny when I was thinking about getting a motorcycle out here,
the stupidest thing you could ever do,
um,
you know,
riding a fucking motorcycle.
I know a lot of guys say,
well you just fucking flew a helicopter.
It's with way safer,
way safer.
There's nobody up there.
I was actually driving back.
I was did,
um,
Mark Marin's podcast promoting season two of F is for family.
I don't know when that's coming out.
MMM.
And thank you to mark Marin.
Forget me on his podcast,
I had a great time.
We talked about anger,
meditation.
We talk music and we help promote any,
help me promote the show.
And um,
I was on my way back.
It was the middle of the day and all of a sudden there was just all this
horrific traffic.
And uh,
this big fucking accident,
this truck had jumped at medium strip.
I don't have to guide median strip.
I don't know if the guy fucking fell asleep or whatever,
but 10 people went to the hospital,
one person died in a dog died,
you know,
so I don't know.
I just think the highway is way,
way,
way more dangerous.
I've said it before,
you flying in formation,
the secure in the fucking blue angels,
everybody's doing 80 miles an hour.
There's no radio contact.
Nobody knows where anybody is fucking going.
These people texting these people on meds,
you have no idea.
And then forget a bit and then right on the other side is another group of
fucking people.
You know,
there's never ending parade of fucking people flying on the other side.
You don't know what they're going to do.
That fucking guy was driving a truck,
fell asleep,
pat a heart attack,
whatever the fuck he did jump the meetings.
Strip went right up and over into oncoming fucking traffic at like,
it was like 12 in the afternoon.
Do you look it up?
It's on was on the five right?
In your Colorado Boulevard.
MMM.
So anyways,
so I was thinking about getting a motorcycle when I was,
I was looking up those moto GP suits.
Yeah.
What's your like 2,500 bucks a whack,
but they got a little air bag in them and I'm like,
well that's what the fuck I would want.
It would be hilarious to buy one of those and then by like a fucking Harley
Davidson and just look like the biggest fucking asshole ever.
You just ride that thing.
If somebody cuts in front of you,
you just let it.
But there's another thing too,
is on those,
when they're racing,
you can lay it down and slide and fucking all that stuff and you find,
you find,
it's not like you can slide into oncoming traffic and there's a good God damn
garbage truck coming at you.
Yep.
MMM.
I Dunno,
but I miss ride motorcycle,
so I'm taking a,
ah,
there's just nothing safe about them.
I was thinking,
all right,
well I'll just get a dirt bike.
I won't go over jumps or anything.
I'll just ride some trails.
But then every,
I've ever been like fucking,
I dunno.
It seems like every six weeks you hear a story about somebody riding on a trail
choosing a mountain bike though.
But if you run like a dirt bike at some mountain line ends up like pouncing on
your back,
which got the helmet on.
I Dunno.
I,
you know what?
This podcast is going great and he just went off the rails somewhere.
I don't really know where.
Let's,
let's do a little bit of,
uh,
advertising Indochino in
the sting wreath,
the Gordon Sumner read it.
Don't shy to talk about how every man looks better in a suit.
You know,
when I'm checking out guys at the outdoor mall,
I'm like,
you know,
I'm really attracted to that guy,
but he's just wearing an Izod,
you know,
with some quarter Roy's,
that's not my all.
Now look at that fellow wearing this suit.
Now there's something I could take home to my parents that said,
everybody,
if you're sick of gay men,
you're not giving you the fucking once over or maybe rolling their eyes.
You ever think that maybe it's not you fucking love handles.
Maybe it's the fact that you don't have on a shirt,
a tie,
and a sport coat to cover up all the mistakes you've made with your nutrition
over the last 40 years.
Thank God there's Indochino is making it easy to get a perfectly tailored suit
and an incredible price.
You can choose from hundreds of top quality fabrics and personalize your suit
just the way you want it,
whether it's for work,
a wedding,
or another special occasion.
Here is how it fucking works.
Visit a showroom or shop online,
[inaudible] dot com pick your fabric.
Choose your customizations from lapels depletes to jacket linings in more.
Submit your measurements,
place your order,
and wait for it to arrive in just a few weeks.
Then they'll sell all this,
your measurements and all that.
She'll sell all of that shit to these fucking nerds making robots.
And next thing you know,
there's going to be a knock at the door and all of a sudden you're going to be
looking right at yourself.
The robot version,
you wearing the suit you wanted and that thing's going to get is you're going to
give up your back.
It's gonna fucking choke you out in no matter how much you tap out,
those robots don't care.
But this week,
my listeners can get any premium Indochino suit for $389.
That's right@indochino.com when entering burr at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for made to fucking measure premium suit.
Three 89 bucks is not a premium suit.
It's a nice suit,
uh,
that Indochino dot.
That's indochino.com promo code [inaudible] for any premium suit for $389 and
free shipping.
Incredible deal for a suit that will fit you better than anything off the rack
ever cooked yet 389 bucks actually for a fucking fitted suit is going to be
great.
You can walk into an Applebee's and every chicken,
there's going to think you're a banker.
You've got to do it.
Next thing you know,
right?
You fucking,
you know,
you ran away trying to block up the smell of that bloomin' onion that she's been
carrying around all day.
All right,
lift everybody you know about Lyft Rye.
It's the APP that gets you a ride in minutes on demand 24 seven for less than
the cost of a cab.
Every Lyft driver is fully vetted through their 10 point safety standard,
including criminal and DMV background checks.
Unlike those other people with that other thing that rhymes with Movember,
right?
You don't know what you're going to get,
You could walk in there with a bloody ax,
those fucking consort higher.
You know,
you'll get around quickly and safety with,
with Lyft,
Lyft drivers are rated after every ride,
so only the best stick around.
You don't have to worry about getting into a filthy car with some creepy dude.
Everybody doesn't get a ribbon at Lyft.
They way they do over it and mover with Lyft,
you can tip in the APP,
which obviously leads to happier drivers.
I mean I not attend Lyft riders get a perfect five star rating from the
passenger.
It's just a better way.
All better.
All around experience.
Bigger isn't always better.
Lift isn't the biggest ride sharing app,
but it is the fastest growing and I have created one.
I'm talking quality over quantity.
Thanks to lift you can get.
It's an easy way to avoid drunk driving.
You never have to bum a ride.
Well what if you're on heroin?
It's another way to to avoid nodding off in public and then I to school that
guy,
oh,
you're in the cab.
Nobody knows.
And you know what a lot of people are actually getting rid of their cars and
relying on Lyft to get around and evidentaly.
I don't blame them.
What are you doing when the apocalypse,
when the zombies come,
you think you can fucking call Lyft that Lyft drivers getting the fuck out of
there right now.
Lyft is offering our listeners a special deal.
Get three rides up to $10 each.
That's a $30 value in case you can't do basic math when you enter Promo code
bill burr,
just download the free Lyft app today and enter the Promo Code bilberry or in
the payment section,
you'll start with three free rides,
up to $10 each.
That's up to a $30 value.
That's Promo Code Bill Burr,
no space,
all caps.
All right.
How many more of these fucking things?
Oh Jesus.
All but these are quick.
He's a quick,
let me tell you some of dollar shave club upside and simply safe.
They respect the fact that I'm not good at reading out loud.
So these are three quick paragraphs.
Here we go.
Run in the table just like the Celtics on the bulls.
Second Rondo sat down,
Bam,
Bam.
Three to two Celtic.
Sorry.
Doll is shave club is the smarter choice.
You'll get a great shave at a great price,
conveniently delivered right to your door.
You do.
You no longer have to Schlep to the store to buy a cheap disposable radios razor
that gives you a cheap shave or spend a fortune on raises with gimmicky shaving
tech you don't need and when you use dollar shave club's the executive razor
with the executive razor.
It comes with the date rape drug in the fucking handle.
Some creepy banker walking around in his gold toed socks shape and is nuts.
No,
that's not what you do.
That's a different read.
Sorry.
The Dollar Shave Club's executive razor with their doctor.
Covey's easy shape.
The blade just gently glides,
giving you a smooth shave.
Dr Carver's shave butter is transparent for a more precise shave,
helps prevent ingrown hairs and fights.
Razor bumps make the smart choice by joining Dollar Shave Club for a limited
time.
New members can get their first month of the executive razor with a tube of
their doctor cavities
for only $5 with free shipping.
And after that the raises are just a few bucks a month.
There's no hidden fees and no commitments.
Cancel anytime you want.
Join the club today@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr that's dollar shave
club.com/burr.
All right.
Upside just sounds like a date movie,
right?
You want to go see upside the downside of the upside.
You want to go see that
stars Tom Hanks.
Meg Ryan,
Hugh fucking let me get a hooker or whatever the fuck his name was.
Who was an English guy?
He used to go out with Elizabeth Berkley.
San Hugh Jackman.
He's the guy who eat a whole chicken every day to become wolverine.
I don't remember Hugh Grant to grant you ready?
You Bet.
He get in the fucking hooker.
Hey,
I never judged that guy.
He got a hawker.
Why?
Why wouldn't you?
What else are you going to do?
What?
Go home and make some fucking Chiffey pop fucking Hugh grant.
You're crushing it.
You're a fucking movie star in your own country.
You go across the pond,
you know?
Oh,
who's kidding?
Who England is like Moto Moto three fucking America is moto GP.
That's what you want to have.
You hit movies.
You guys all know it's true.
Christ,
you're all still in our blue jeans.
You all,
you are,
you're,
you hate us,
but you love our culture.
Isn't it safe to say that I'm fucking with,
he actually motion looking jeans can completely reset.
All right.
Upside.
There's a better way for you to buy business travel.
It's called upside.com.
Every time you buy a trip it upside,
you'll save your company a ton of money and they give you an Amazon card with
hundreds of dollars upsides able to do this because they bundle your flights and
hotels together for one low price.
That's what they do.
They rip this seats out of a commercial airliner and they just stuff you in
there.
You know,
you might think flying,
standing up like you're at a mosh pit for six hours from New York to La might
suck.
Yeah.
Talks to me when you that only cost you 40 bucks.
Now that's not what they do.
Um,
bundle pricing saves money.
This is what they do.
If you're a frequent business traveler,
you're company saves a ton of money and you could get thousands a year and gift
cards just for buying your air and hotel together and upside.
You just fucking said this.
Plus you still get your miles.
Do what the,
I feel like in the end of this you can be missing a kidney.
This seems like too,
too good a deal.
And I get a gift card and I get to keep my miles and I saved them a bunch of
money.
If you shopping for business travel and you'd be crazy not to check out
upside.com you're out of your mind.
It just takes three minutes to see how much you can save by buying your flights
and hotels together for one low price.
Oh,
I see.
They both cut side deals with each other.
Somebody's gotta be doing,
you know,
at some point somebody gets sold into fucking sex slavery here.
This is just too good a deal.
And right now the human trait,
right?
And right now when you use my name bur you're guaranteed to get at least a 100
Amazon gift card.
Your first trip.
That's my name.
[inaudible] to get at least $100 Amazon gift card free.
Save big on travel and get a big gift card every trip.
I love upside.com evidently upside.com minimum purchase required.
See Site for complete details are right.
Here's the last one,
everybody.
It's simply safe
if you're not there when a fire starts,
simply safe can be there to save your home.
Want those instead of fucking throw you into it.
I wasn't there,
but we'll put,
we'll put you right back in it.
It's kind of a good thing if you're not there when the fire starts,
right?
Okay.
Simply safe can be there to save your home.
All right.
This is a robot that has a fire extinguisher.
What is this with simply safe home security,
you'll get a 24 seven connection to dispatch and lightning fast responses times
in emergencies.
All right,
I have to look up dispatch.
What does dispatch,
Oh,
I know is I have 24 fucking
24 hour access to dispatch.
dispatch.com that's not what I wanted.
That's not what I wanted.
Don't you wish there was like voice command on these things?
Okay.
Then you can be to be like,
what did you want?
What did you want?
Yeah.
Oh for fuck's sakes.
It'll load eventually.
I'll tell you what that means later.
Dispatch.
Oh,
here it is.
It is a
okay
sendoff.
Oh fucking Christ.
I just happened to,
come on now want a to get the send off to destination or for a purpose deal with
the task,
the sending of someone or something to a destination for a purpose.
So they're going to send somebody who has a purpose in life to your house.
When it's on fire,
they're going to walk up the street holding their fucking head.
Hi.
I'm imagining that person would,
you know,
be driving a fire fire engine.
Right?
All right.
The system is easy to use and completely wireless.
You can install it yourself in under an hour.
No one installation guy drilling holes in your walls.
No ugly wires.
Simply safe's founder and chief engineer thought of everything when he built
this system.
Backup batteries for your base section station.
Sorry,
a cellular connection to the authorities.
There are no long term contracts,
no commitment to no hidden fees.
Simply safe's round the clock.
Professional security monitoring is just 1499 a month.
Order today and you'll get a special 10% discount.
Go to simply safe bird.com that's s I,
m p l I s a f e burg.com for 10% off your home security system.
Simply safe.com simply safe burrow.com sorry.
All right.
Is that it?
I think I talked about everything,
right?
Yeah.
I believe I hit everything that I want to talk about.
You know,
I was just checking in on you some
fucking music.
Excuse me,
that you guys can listen to a man.
We got another like half hour of stuff from classic podcasts from a Thursday or
a Monday and a year,
a day a week gone by.
That's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I believe there's another f one race this Sunday.
Check it out if you can.
Uh,
let's go sell dicks.
I'm hoping for a classic.
I hope he went,
but I also want to see Rhonda would come on and do his thing too.
You know what I mean?
Cause I still love that guy.
He's still a Celtic to me.
All right,
that's it.
Have a great weekend and I'll talk to you on Monday.
[inaudible]
locked in Bro.
Hey,
what the fuck I'm talking about?
We decided to have a fucking party for a new place.
You don't you think that was my idea.
Do you think it was my idea to have a bunch of strangers come into the fucking
house?
I'll have people over.
That's what I do.
Hey,
you want to come over and watch the game?
Nine people that I know,
right?
Have all your fucking phone numbers.
You don't.
Nia is a more open person,
so she's like,
let's have a party.
All right,
so we still,
she goes to invite your friends.
So I'm alright.
So,
you know,
I got,
I'm a,
I'm a guy,
I don't have a bunch of friends.
Okay.
I got six good friends for that I could really trust,
you know,
it's about it,
at least out here.
Then over here in neah talking to her mom about all excited about the party and
she's like,
yeah,
I sent it on a Facebook and I was just like,
oh my God,
did I just invite 110 paypal?
And my heart literally sank going,
please tell me you didn't just invite 110 fucking people.
She's like,
don't worry,
they're not all going to show up.
It's like,
yeah,
but like a third wheel.
And then they're going to bring people that you don't even fucking know.
And that's exactly what happened.
It was a fucking great party.
I'm not gonna lie to you,
but I got to like,
I got to learn how to,
I'll be,
I thought I was going to be a good host.
I wasn't.
I was all right with the people I knew.
But the people I didn't know.
Uh,
actually most of them are all right,
but there were a couple of them.
I just find it just sends you something fucking annoying about somebody you
don't know,
sitting on your goddamn couch,
you know,
eating your food,
drinking your booze.
He like,
who the food of fuck are you?
It's somebody else was laying down on the floor.
I felt like the kids' Dad,
I want to make,
get and get a fucking job,
right?
It's over.
It's 26 she fucking pumped.
So anyway,
so the party is going great.
And uh,
I'm basically the whole time,
you know,
not drinking too much,
but I'm standing by the front door cause that's the only way out.
All right?
And nobody's walking out with any of my shit,
right?
I'm acting basically like psycho in fucking stripes.
That's how I am.
It's how I'm wired.
All right?
So,
uh,
fucking three quarters away through the party,
everything's going great.
And I'm like,
wow,
this is,
you know what?
I forgot.
I'm not 21 anymore.
I'm fucking 43.
All my friends are adults and everybody's drinking responsibly.
And no one's really hammered,
nothing got broken,
everything's cool.
So I'll start,
just as I was starting to relax,
some kid comes up to me,
he's like,
ah,
yeah,
you own the house.
And I'm like,
well,
the bank owns it.
I'm fucking paying it off.
What can I do for you?
And he's like a yes,
kind of embarrassing.
But I used the bathroom downstairs and uh,
it's clog now.
And I was wondering if he had a plunger.
And I was like,
yeah,
I do have a plunger.
I got plunger right here in the upstairs bathroom.
So I give it to the guy and I,
and I say,
man,
I appreciate your honesty.
He goes,
no problem.
He goes downstairs,
he takes care of it,
comes back,
he wants again.
He goes,
he goes,
sorry about that.
I said,
not at all,
not at all.
What the fuck?
It's a toilet,
you know,
plugs up every once in a while.
But I appreciate,
I appreciate your honesty.
You know,
cause that would have been nasty.
Good for you.
Right.
So,
uh,
now the couple hours goes by the party ends and there's like one straggler left.
And I tell the story to knee.
I'm like,
you know what a good,
what a good guy.
What a good shit.
No Pun intended.
You know,
he could have left it in there.
And then the other party I come walking in my fucking bathroom,
looks like a Goddamn port authority bus station,
toilet,
you know,
so site.
So,
so one of the stragglers at the party goes,
yeah,
he goes,
I saw that whole thing go down.
That's not exactly how it went down.
I'm like,
what he talking about?
He goes,
he goes,
it wasn't him that was in the bathroom.
And I go,
who was,
he goes,
it was his girlfriend.
Some lay
took a dump of a magnitude that it wouldn't go down the toilet.
So now she's in there panicking and this is when today's technology kicks in.
She can it back in the day,
she would had to crawl the fucking window
and hope nobody saw her and just left the door locked.
Everybody would have panicked.
Holy Fuck,
who's in there?
Did somebody pass out to somebody.
If somebody committed suicide,
some of what?
It kicked in the door,
right?
Knocked it off the fucking goddamn hinges and you go in there,
that'd be nobody in there.
You'd feel the air from outside and then look down and everyone would see a
giant shit and be like,
as a party would be over and the owner of the house would be walking around
going home.
What one are you mother fucking Jerry,
you better drive away.
Right.
That's how I would have ended.
But because of today's technology,
not saying she didn't panic,
you know,
it's even worse as a lady cause they're not even supposed to do stuff like that.
Right.
And uh,
she was able to text your boyfriend and I would fucking pay at least $400 to
read those texts,
the panic in those texts.
And to his credit,
he fucking eats,
stepped it up.
He took the hit,
he came up to me,
v h ones I love the eighties own Belper and said,
I took a dump in your toilet to a magnitude it didn't go down.
And I need the tools required to alleviate this situation.
So
Anti Douche bag of the week,
that guy right there.
So taking a fucking bullet for the team that gets that right there is the
reverse Peyton manning award.
He didn't fucking go,
we had protection issues right now.
He took one,
he took one for the fucking tape,
went upstairs like a Goddamn gentlemen asked for a plunger,
gave it to him and it was all fun.
And I went down there at the end of the party.
You never would've known anything,
anything happen.
You know what I mean?
Like,
uh,
you know,
three hours after the Kennedy assassination.
I bet it was.
It was all I would say it,
you know,
marked it all up and everything was all figured out,
but it was a nice road.
Again,
mopped up the brains.
What am I talking about?
Yeah.
[inaudible] Hey,
what's going going
on?
It's bill burn.
It is the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
April 20 something 2009.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
You know,
I really don't.
All right.
I feel like shit.
Uh,
I had a really rough weekend in a Columbus,
Ohio.
But before I get into the details,
I want to thank everyone who came out on a Friday,
Saturday,
and Sunday.
I had a great time.
I had too good of a time.
Let's put it that way.
Um,
yeah.
Too good a time to go to fucking time.
And I'm paying for it right now.
You know,
I don't know why I keep doing this.
I don't know why.
I just can't learn,
you know?
You know,
I always do overrated,
underrated on this shit.
They all,
you know what's fucking underrated?
Eight hours sleep,
you know,
you know what's,
you know what's fucking underrated going,
hey,
you want another shot at Jamieson?
You know what?
No,
I think I've had enough.
You know what I would like?
I would like a water that's underrated.
You know,
not going to fucking steak and shake at three in the morning.
That's underrated.
Yeah.
One of those fucking double burgers I never even made at that place before.
It didn't even look like meat like a patty in order.
Patty looks like.
Sure.
We all do.
We've all had a fucking burger.
Even you little Veggie cons out there,
you know what it looks like.
This is a little burned up wig and there was two of them.
You know what?
I was kind of a 40 year old fucking guy going to be 41 and fucking June goes to
steak and shake at three in the fucking morning when he's got a Goddamn fucking
eight 40 in the morning flight.
Why would you do that?
Schererville you suck at math.
We all know that,
but you can tell time.
I know there's numbers involve of Jesus Christ.
What a fucking idiot.
This whole fucking
yes.
I just started thinking about that boogie nights.
I'm a fucking idiot.
I'm a fucking Elliot and I'm a fucking Eddie and I fucking idiot.
Twice Friday night ended up at steak and shake at three in the morning,
you know,
fucking Sunday night I was as far as,
I didn't walk in and they weren't like norm,
like on chairs areas again,
all shit faced.
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking motley crew.
You want to see a motley crew go to a fucking steak and shake at three in the
fucking morning.
Yeah.
Good God Almighty.
Now I'll tell you I was part of the problem.
Oh,
you know,
I bet I was doing it.
Everybody else was doing,
they were all sitting in their shit face looking around.
Everybody else.
Go on Jesus Christ.
Look at,
Oh,
that fucking guy.
Oh my God.
Look at her.
She's wearing slippers.
Jesus Christ.
You know you don't even realize they're doing it to you too.
I'm going to have fucking guy.
Huh?
Look at that.
Look at his fucking eyes.
What does,
it's almost like he's been drinking Jameson all night.
Why wouldn't you get a water after awhile?
What a fucking idiot.
Yeah.
Let me have one year burnt up wig.
Fucking burgers.
Ah.
Why is shit food so good when you,
when when you shit faced,
you know?
Is that what it is?
Shit.
Face Shit.
Food is just,
it's just all shit shit.
Fucking decisions.
I didn't want to do that,
man.
I was doing well.
You know,
I went to trader Joe's,
you know,
dodged a bunch of fucking Birkenstock hippies and I,
I went in there and I,
I,
I got the fridge put in my room.
Fuck global warming.
I want to be in shape.
I had a fridge put in my room.
I,
oh I had done all this healthy food and what do I do?
What do I do?
I go out,
I go drinking two,
one of four nights like a fucking moron.
Oh my God.
I went to this one.
You know what I had,
I had a slice of pizza last night too.
That's how fucked up I was.
This is like all coming.
It's like a slide show,
you know,
you can't remember this shit that happened in between,
but you just,
you just have pictures.
Good.
God Almighty was at a bad looking pizza.
Is there anything fucking worse than that?
Just a bad look and it just,
you know,
lets you know when someone makes a pizza right and even sucks when it's hot,
but then it just sits there for awhile and it just gets that,
that a cold case file.
Look to it.
You know what I mean?
Like it should have a fucking toe tag hanging off the crust.
They,
they brought over a whole pie to look like that,
you know,
they looked like some five year old made it and like an easy bake oven,
and you're their parents and I,
you have to eat it and say,
oh,
Susie,
it's delicious.
You know,
just begin.
Begin her little life of people lying to her and not being fucking honest
saying,
no,
don't wear that.
You look fat in that now.
You just go,
oh,
Susie,
you look beautiful.
That's an excellent pizza you made.
You don't,
Susie,
it fucking sucks.
All right.
I'm not saying to give up your dream about being a cook,
but you definitely don't fucking have any talent at this point in your life.
You know,
maybe we can send you to some sort of,
uh,
oh Jesus Christ.
What are those chefs schools called?
Huh?
Well,
what does that art called?
You know,
come on.
You know what it is because with a c,
it's not custodial.
It's not calm.
Macerich he plays for fucking the Canadians.
Oh Canadians.
I want to say a bone,
Julia to all my friends up there in Montreal.
You know,
I was just breaking your balls.
I've been blogging for the Bruins and uh,
is basically I went down as blogging for the Bruins during the playoffs,
which I'm going to continue to do because they swept the Montreal Canadians.
Um,
and basically,
uh,
you know,
I have to blog for the Bruins and playing the Canadians.
I mean,
what do,
what do you,
what am I going to say?
The Canadians won 24 cups.
We've only won five.
We haven't won since 1972.
All I can do is just try to piss you off.
That's all I was doing.
I was,
Montreal fans get really,
really fucking mad.
You know,
I made fun of their coach.
I just did what I get.
Oh,
I just made fun of how they looked,
how they blew their fucking players.
I don't need any more.
I said I was just trying to be a jerk and then people got all just garners noise
.
You were hockey.
You know,
there's guy himself,
a comedian.
I don't think this is very funny.
Whatever.
I,
you know,
it's fucking funny.
I heard Celine Dion is thinking about buying the Montreal Canadiens.
He's probably gonna move into Vegas.
There'll be a fucking mascot on ice.
That would be,
that would be a crime.
That'd be a goddamn crime.
All right.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
This is the hangover episode of the Monday morning podcast.
I am sitting in a hotel in Manhattan,
New York.
Why are you doing that,
bill?
Huh?
You lay in low after your weekend of Busan.
Now I've got a week at Caroline's and I'm working with Joe to Rosa once again,
my partner in crime too.
Codependent fucking alcoholics.
Do you know one time,
I don't think I might have told this story on ONA opion Anthony Show for you.
Uh,
people who live in,
I don't know,
fucking North Dakota.
Um,
I don't know when I was in Caroline's Caroline's comedy club on Broadway,
where I will be Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday and Sunday for a fucking 22 shows,
22 fucking shows.
I can't even do one show at this point.
I'm laying low,
man.
I'm laying low.
Um,
but anyways,
one night I was,
I was standing there at the bar and I decided,
I didn't know if I decided I wasn't going to drink,
but I just wasn't drinking,
you know,
and all of a sudden who comes walking down the stairs,
like some starlet in the 1950s,
making a big fucking debut,
Joe de Rosa do you think was missing was the fuck in the evening gown.
He comes fucking Walson down the stairs,
you know,
all dainty,
like,
and the second I saw him I was like,
fuck,
now I got a drink.
Right.
And you know what,
he was thinking the exact same thing.
That was the funny thing.
Neither one of us wanted to drink.
You got any friends like that?
You just,
you just been fuck ups for so long that neither one of you can just pull you out
of the tailspin.
I'm sure.
Anybody who's in in Aa good.
Tell me what exactly that that's called.
What kind of friendship that is?
Um,
I don't fucking know.
I really,
really feel like shit right now.
And,
uh,
so I'm sitting in the room and,
if you noticed the quality might be a little bit better.
Actually got a microphone now and I have a little mixer and I have my headphones
on and I'm sitting here in the fucking dark.
That's not true.
I got the one little desk light on,
uh,
basically talking to myself.
You know,
technically once you start listening,
this whole thing makes sense.
But Right now before I upload this thing,
this is really,
uh,
you know,
he says,
why they don't give everybody handguns.
Because if one was laying around,
I'm fucking with you.
You know what I would do?
I'd probably pointed out the window.
I wouldn't shoot anybody.
Just try to scare someone,
maybe make me laugh and I could get a little oxygen or something into my fucking
head.
What do you guys see?
What do you guys use for hangovers?
Huh?
Other than the smart thing,
not drink anymore.
God Damn.
It's just so much fun though.
You know,
I was having a great time,
you know,
there was broad,
just having a good fucking time.
Just a good time.
You know the other fucking people who like to drink.
I met a couple of hunters.
I met a couple of dancers.
I met you.
I met a,
you know,
a nice mix of people as I'm a fucking weird dude man.
I don't like people before I get on stage,
like I don't want to see him.
I don't see anybody in the fucking crowd.
But the second the show's over,
if somebody is cool,
I,
I that's the part of the show I I enjoy and I become like this fucking uh,
Charlie rose and I just started interviewing people.
You know.
What's it like to shoot a pheasant in the face?
Huh?
What's that like?
You know,
do you got a little fucking couple of pieces of wood that you rubbed together
and somehow it sounds like a pheasant going a Eddie come on over here,
you know,
or whatever fucking pheasants names are.
If you had a pet pheasant,
what would you name it?
Huh?
Larry?
That'd be a great name for a pheasant.
Has to be funny if you had it right.
And people looking at it like,
oh my God,
is it a pheasant?
Like Larry,
get the fuck off of that thing.
Actually got off of it,
you know,
and then he got on a late night talk show and then you went out there and then
it didn't work.
And then the host sorta mugged about how it didn't work and then maybe takes a
turn on his fucking wingtip shoe and 50 years later it's part of the greatest
hits DVD,
you know?
And little did you know that that was the pinnacle of your life is a fucking
zookeeper.
That one moment you thought it was going to keep happening?
No.
One episode,
one episode you would never asked back because your animal shit on the fucking
host shoe
wasn't supposed to do that.
It didn't do,
they didn't do it in the rehearsals.
All right,
how the fuck am I going to maneuver this here?
All the rattling in the background.
I couldn't move my mixer or you know,
I feel right now I feel like the fucking unit Obama all this,
Goddamn,
was he anti-technology though?
I don't know if he was anti or pro at all.
I know he was definitely fucking alone and was a paranoid son of a bitch.
My back.
There we go.
You guys get nervous there for a second.
What the fuck does too many fucking cords here.
I'm going to go back to this cell phone.
I'm not on holding my fucking laptop like a Goddamn,
you know,
like,
servants used to hand shit to kings.
Would they put something on a pillow and then they had the little hands
underneath it?
That's the way I'm holding it.
I'll tell you what,
can I paint a fucking picture?
Can I paint a goddamn picture?
Let me,
let me adjust the microphone.
I want to tell you about my microphone.
By the way,
do you remember back in the 1970s,
you know,
nowadays,
whenever somebody has a Mike,
uh,
and they have like a little filter on that,
a filter or whatever,
I don't know,
the technical,
you know,
little spongy thing that you stick on there so it doesn't pop or if there's some
sort of wind,
you know,
nowadays that just black and it just looks like a,
fucking giant just sitting there.
Right.
And something that they can put on TV,
you know.
But back in the day,
man,
the 70s,
you know,
when people were buying weed by the fucking garbage bag full and uh,
the 70s were colorful man,
you fucking day just start it off.
You know,
they had that crazy cereal that they used to have somebody brought up booberry
or count Chocula and Franken Berry and I was in the cereal aisle.
Uh,
you know,
the other day when I,
when I went to trader Joe's,
when I was going to have a healthy week before I down five bottles of whiskey on
the worst drunk too.
I'm one of those guys,
I fucking call up people and start telling him I love him,
you know,
and one of those guys,
I,
I do everything but end up in the drunk tank on the fucking Andy Griffith show
him such an old school drunk.
But I'm not an angry guy when I get drunk.
I'm really not.
I'm actually pleasant and I'm able to emote.
Is that why you do it,
Bill?
I don't fucking know.
Oh,
I know.
It was,
it makes me feel like shit.
The fuck was I just talking about,
oh,
how coat color for the 70s where yeah.
You'd start off with that fucking cereal that they had and uh,
and with one of the worst sentences ever.
Yeah.
He started off with that cereal that they had.
Oh,
there you go,
Bill.
It's a great way to,
to fucking start it off,
right.
If you're patting yourself on the back about how you could paint a visual,
you know,
it's funny,
I've headphones on right now.
I have no idea how loud I'm talking and I'm sure that there is somebody on the
other side of this wall that is contemplating calling the front desk,
but what they're listening to is so fucking bizarre.
They haven't been able to tap out yet.
Um,
well let's Eric and bill.
Maybe they're listening in your sound fucking annoying.
All right.
Whatever.
Stop Heckling yourself.
Get to the point.
Yeah,
you'd start off,
you eat tricks,
you need booberry the shit literally changed the color of your milk,
which is some really hacky comedy from fucking the 80s but I'm telling you,
you had that shit going on honeycomb,
you know the,
the fucking people were wearing polyester.
I mean Shit was loud in the 70s you know,
those plaid slacks,
people had slacks,
he had boots had set up the side.
They're all fucking shiny.
Women had like those,
those plastic looking purses.
It was fucking freaky.
It was weird.
Everything was like done.
Suddenly I think that the advertisers just like,
look,
everybody's on drugs so we,
we really need to enhance their trip.
So much shit in the 70s was like really done
to like even like the fucking monkeys,
which I guess you know was that this was the late sixties I think it went to the
early seventies we were one when they used to fucking,
you know,
pretend to sing in,
pretend to play instruments at the end of the show there and they would,
they would cut to that little musical montage is and they'd always do like half
the time they would do like those,
they'd put it in like a kaleidoscope.
So he had them actually in the middle and then like six of them like going
around like a fucking that go fucking revolver aside.
I don't know what it was.
And you're eating that cereal.
He just watching this shit.
Anyways,
this all comes around to my microphone.
Back then you couldn't even watch like a sports show without sort of tripping,
you know what I mean?
Like they had ABC's wide world of sport and they had these fucking bright yellow
sport coats on and they used to have these microphones and when they stood
outside,
the little spongy thing that they stuck on top wasn't black.
It didn't blend in with the microphone.
There were these crazy colors.
And one that I always remember was there was always like bright orange.
It made no fucking sense.
But as a kid I liked it.
So whatever I bought a microphone in,
the guy goes,
what kind of wind screen do you want?
You know,
you want the standard black one?
I said,
fuck that.
I want that one.
Keith Jackson used to use when he do Monday night football way back in the day,
or we do the college games.
Remember Keith Jackson?
Huh?
Hello again.
Everybody that says keep Jackson.
Remember that guy?
Alabama,
Crimson tide and I'm fucking wolverines I Michigan,
they're going to be Schwab and paint.
Um,
anyways.
Yeah,
so that's what I got here.
That was a really long fucking way to go to explain that.
I put an orange spongy thing in the end of my fucking Mike and I'm a Jew.
I know I'm cursing a lot right now and I'm cursing.
I'm not cursing at you guys.
Okay?
Sometimes people get confused.
Stop cursing at me.
I'm not cursing at you and cursing at my hangover because I described shit to
you.
All right?
Jesus Christ.
Look at this fucking fake wood in this desk.
This is the kind of desk that you sit,
you know that you sit at when you're like confessing to a murder.
You know what I mean?
He just sitting in and trying to wear you down.
They bring in some food and I can like,
they're your friends.
I was just watching those fucking cold case files,
man.
God Damn.
Most things are creepy.
It is fucking creepy.
Just watching the people when they come in and,
and they,
they get in question for the murder and they just sounded like,
you know,
regular,
regular guys.
Where were you that night?
Oh,
you know,
I was home,
watching a basketball game,
you know,
you're chilling out
at a p to
find out he fucking hacks up 23 people.
Then when they,
when they,
when they admit it,
they're like,
oh yeah,
yeah,
I did it.
You know,
they,
they found this one guy that,
that,
uh,
who's that fucking guy that the green river,
I know,
they always got to give them nicknames,
the fucking news so they can sell more papers.
They give them nicknames like they're going to the rose bowl or some shit,
you know,
crazy like Johnson,
he's killed 48 fucking people.
They call me ice iceman.
Um,
anyways,
so there,
there's one guy up in Seattle,
right?
He killed all these,
all these women who was brutal and uh,
they picked the guy up.
He never been arrested before and they,
they,
they meet him outside of his job cause they put together a case.
Okay.
He has no idea that they're onto them and they,
they,
the cops come up to the guy and they say,
listen buddy,
uh,
where,
you know,
fucking whatever the police officer's it to try to get a headache.
I don't know what the fuck they say.
You know,
they say,
hi,
we're cops and we're here to arrest you for the murder of four women.
Now if you never been arrested before,
when your heart drop,
the guy just is like,
he,
I guess evidently he just went,
okay.
Then they brought him down there,
he confessed to that and he confessed to like fucking 60 other women that he had
killed.
So they bring this guy into,
uh,
another room to talk to a,
to a psychologist,
you know,
cause he wants to try to break them down so you can figure out so you can stop
these maniacs.
Right.
And He,
they asked the guy this question,
they said,
uh,
you know,
if you could,
um,
you could pick out one thing about your personality that you feel is different
from the average person walking down the street,
what would that be?
And without missing a beat,
the guy said,
ah,
that,
that whole caring thing.
Wow.
You know when you think you don't give a fuck Jesus Christ.
Just regular.
Yeah.
The whole Karen,
that whole caring thing.
Yeah.
I just don't seem to give a fuck.
It's weird.
You know?
I don't know.
I hate watching that.
I don't know why I watch that show.
That show literally gives me nightmares.
You know what I mean?
You start thinking about what?
This is not funny.
What the fuck am I talking about?
See,
this is what happens.
This is what happens when you go out boozing.
I,
you know what the sad thing is,
is I know at some point,
at some point this weekend,
I'm probably going to do this again,
but fortunately I'm in New York City,
so I want end up at a steak and shake.
I've never eaten there.
I think I've made fun of that fucking place
on these podcasts.
How would you rate,
how would you guys out there?
Huh?
All my listeners out there.
Please tell me you listening.
Please tell me I'm not.
I'm done.
Just sitting here baking under this fucking hotel lamp for nothing.
How would you rate the worst?
Your worst?
Like a fast food,
you know what I mean?
Everybody,
you know,
no one wants to eat it,
but we all eat it cause you know,
it tastes good.
Fucking tastes good.
But then there's,
there's certain ones,
either you had,
either you had a bad experience or you,
uh,
just the look of it,
you know,
like got,
let's say for me like Taco Bell,
I just can't go in there.
There's just something about the colors on the sign.
They,
it just makes my stomach hurt.
You know,
you just get that awful feeling in your stomach.
I fell the same way about that.
Like,
Arby's,
you've never fucked with Arby's
and Mcdonald's guy.
I'm old school.
I like Mcdonald's
in and outers this shit.
But you know,
I got a lot of memories as a kid at Mcdonald's.
So I think that one's still wins even though in and out is even better.
But there's just certain ones I won't even go into,
you know?
All right guys,
I'm fucking and fast.
Jesus Christ.
I need a fucking water or something.
The hell that I do with that water didn't have water around here.
Hang on a second.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Fucking water I should had last night.
All right,
let's,
let's get on with the questions here.
Um,
if you're new to my page,
you probably think I'm out of my fucking mind and you would be right.
I am out of my mind.
But you know what?
You know what?
I don't have anything to say to that.
I am guilty as charged.
What are you fucking perfect.
Why don't you go to the city to fucking www?
I'm fucking perfect.com and go listen to that podcast.
I bet there's a lot of fucking lapse on that one.
You know?
Did they got a mixer?
I've got a fucking mixer.
Bitch.
You liked that shit.
I'm learning a lot of computer stuff.
You know what?
How about you guys make me computer literate?
Can you do that for me?
I'll start off with something really easy.
Something that really fucking annoys me on my computer.
And you know what?
Maybe someone else does.
This isn't,
maybe this annoys someone else who has a computer who also has a drinking
problem.
Okay.
And then,
uh,
you know,
I'll read how to do it and maybe I can help something,
another drunk out there.
All right.
This is one of my problems that I have
when I go to you when I go into to apple works,
right?
The text is so fucking small.
I don't understand it.
It's set.
I know how to change it,
but I gotta change it every time.
All right.
Right now it's stuck on 12.
Okay.
Which is basically squint size and you know,
when I copy and paste your guys' emails into my fucking thing,
it's,
it,
it makes it smaller.
I don't know what it's doing.
I wanted at 18,
I want the default set at 18.
How the fuck do I do that in apple works?
I've got a brand new MAC book.
I want to learn how to do that.
Okay.
I want to learn some shit.
You know,
I know how to upload.
I know how to do this now.
Look at me.
I don't know how to Upload Shit.
I'll turn it into a fucking MP3.
I'll send it right to you.
I know how to do that now.
I feel great.
It's my new opening line when I hit on chicks in the road.
You know what's up,
sweetie?
How are you doing?
You'd like to show you,
you know,
I can also upload audio files and turn them into an MP.
Three.
Huh?
Put it on a desktop.
I'll fucking drag it right over there.
Same Way.
I'm going to drag you across the fucking carpet in my Kotel.
What the fuck is that?
All right.
Can somebody teach me how to do that,
please?
Okay,
and let's get on with the podcast here.
You know what the problem is?
Is this not enough fucking room here?
Oh,
I got it.
Why don't I just move this dude,
I even have a little stand here for my microphone.
I have a little fucking stand.
This is like a,
I don't know.
This is one of these like really nerdy things that if you start when you're 18
by the time you're 30 you're famous and you're not a nerd anymore.
Like chicks one,
fuck you had sun,
it's unreal.
But when you start this at 40,
it's just pathetic and sad.
Okay,
here we go.
We're going to go to a,
I already did the underrated.
So why don't I do over it?
Um,
I know this is really,
this is really coming off grumpy.
I understand.
But whatever,
you know,
last week I was pissed.
This week on grumpy.
You know what I'm doing for a happy one.
How about next week?
Okay,
next week I'll be all bubbly.
I won't because I'll be flying across this country.
Oh man,
that's gonna suck.
Let's not think about that.
Do you know like I literally fall asleep on the plane.
I've flown across this country so many fucking times that I can literally look
down and pretty much guess what stayed.
I'm over,
you know,
as a passenger I can do that.
Why these levels so low but the fuck is going on.
There we go.
Might not talking into this thing.
Hello.
Test.
There we go.
You know what I mean?
I can look out,
I can tell,
you know,
pretty good.
I mean,
Rick.
Yeah,
I dunno.
Wait a minute.
What the fuck am I bragging about?
What?
Southwest is a desert.
You get into Colorado,
you've got the mountains,
starts getting flat.
You're like,
all right,
this is Nebraska,
Kansas.
Maybe we were in Iowa.
You start seeing more lights.
You moving towards fucking
into Illinois.
Right?
And that all works.
I don't fucking know.
Like I actually like I recognize like lakes now.
You know I can look down on my watch.
Ah,
you know what?
It's taken this long.
We're right about here and we should be seeing Cleveland comment by there.
It is.
There it is.
I look down.
Sometimes we'll look at fucking stadiums.
So all my fucking life is now.
If I could be outside the plane and look at my stupid roundhead looking out of
that little oval fucking window.
This is what I signed up for.
This is how fucking hung over I am.
I'm actually bitching that I'm a comedian.
Something that I wanted to do something that I decided to do.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
There was a way for you guys to email me a fucking tampon.
I think I get like 9 million this week.
All right.
Uh,
here we go.
Let's read the overrate it.
All right.
Let's get into your thoughts.
I think you've heard enough from me for one week.
All right.
Overrated bill.
Build a,
I think this is overrated.
A lot of people don't talk about this.
This is coming from a woman.
She says,
male strippers are overrated.
She said,
especially when they are hired a for a Bachelorette party.
Is it me or does,
uh,
Jesus Christ,
I can't read when I'm fucking not hung over.
She goes,
is it me or does anyone else think this is the stupidest waste of 125 bucks
they've ever seen?
You guys get strippers for 125 bucks?
Jesus.
Is there anything that sucks about being a woman?
Yeah.
Given birth periods.
All right.
You're right.
Sorry.
Um,
yeah.
Okay.
Name was,
let me get back to this.
Yeah,
the guys are all,
the guys were all muscled up and everything,
but to be honest,
when you see women looking at male strippers and they're hooting and hollering
and laughing and laughing it up with their,
they're actually laughing at the stripper.
Yes,
it is true that they are likely some women who enjoy it and thinking this guy
would probably be awesome in bed,
but 95% of women are hysterically laughing at the Ridiculous Man All oiled up in
his g string with his stupid little boombox playing NXS what you need,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
she just,
there you go.
She's painting a picture there.
That's what you need and a good story and you need a narrator who's not fucking
grumpy and hung over anyways,
playing what you need.
Gyrating around the living room and dry humping.
Dad's lazy boy.
You know what?
Jesus Christ,
uh,
blah,
blah.
This is really fucking long.
Let me get to the point here.
She says,
women,
what women want is women want a man who was a man,
kills spiders,
drink beer,
et cetera.
None of us would picture our man acting like a sex machine with a wax chess
dancing in front of a group of housewives.
A man will offer my girl a man will offer,
my girlfriend is a stripper and he knows his buddies will congratulate them like
God,
Dude,
you go friends and strip it.
That's awesome.
A woman would never offer the same information.
Why?
Because she knows the response from other woman would be a snicker and a yikes.
Gee,
I'm so sorry.
Look,
is that true?
The women really not like don't just like cougars,
don't they like male strippers?
You know?
If you want to know what it's like to be a guy,
be a woman in your,
as far as like our sex drive,
you know I,
I think maybe a woman once you're in your forties at that time I didn't know
what the fuck point I'm trying to make there.
I just know that like older women act like the same level of retarded.
That guys act like
our entire fucking wise.
When they start to get older.
I don't know what it is.
I guess it's safe.
They finally don't give a shit.
And they could admit that they like cock or they like sex,
you know,
cause before they have to be like,
well,
you know,
it's just for procreation or I just like my boyfriend's cock.
I don't have any other fucking fantasies,
you know?
Whereas guys,
we just get,
we could just get to be pigs.
We just get to be the God pigs that we are.
But you know what?
You get to cry at movies and get that shit out.
I get to hold it in.
You know what?
There was a rough one was that Harvey milk movie.
The amount of Shit I had to think about,
so I wouldn't tear up there in that movie just so I wouldn't be failing.
You know,
as a guy,
you can't fucking cry.
So I got to sit there and be like,
you know,
he's,
he's going through some shit.
I know everyone was getting all sad when a,
you know,
when he gets whacked there,
you know.
So in order to,
not to get emotional myself,
I just thought,
you know what,
if someone just came over and just kicked him right in the balls
and I just started laughing,
you know,
that's what it is.
That's what comedy is.
It's to stop from crying.
All right.
Um,
number two.
Oh,
this is,
oh my God,
this,
some New Yorkers aren't gonna like this one.
This is another thing that she says,
oh,
is overrated is underrated.
Actually a two run homer in the bottom of the ninth,
ninth after Mary off of Marianna Rivera.
And I could've fucking read that better.
Yeah,
the red sox swept the Yankees.
Man.
This fucking unbelievable.
There'll be back.
This shit always happens.
One team always jumps out in front of the other team,
right?
And then we
do,
we fucking own you guys.
You feel good on you.
Good.
And then they literally almost like it's fixed.
Now.
The Yankees will sweep us down there and we'll play each other like 12 times or
13 times and someone will win when it fucking seven to six.
It's a Goddamn business people.
Okay.
There's no fucking Santa Claus Hunter.
I don't buy it.
Um,
and we stole home plate and you know,
how the fuck does that happen?
$200 million team.
You know something.
You realize the red sox sale,
they're only there number four this year as far as money spent.
Oh yeah.
A lot of you fuckers didn't know that.
Did you?
Yankee spent 200 million then it's the mets then I believe the cubs and then us.
We're 122 million.
Isn't that great?
Now we're going to act like where some little fucking starving panty,
little Pansy fucking team
Yankee did ruin in baseball.
Um,
who gives a fuck?
I'll tell you what's funny is that the,
the the fuck did I just do there?
I'm going to sit on my computer.
All right,
let's let you know what I'm really starting to feel like I'm losing the momentum
of this 31 minutes.
31 hung over minutes.
Dude.
I'm going to tell you right now,
this is feeling like four hours.
I feel like I'm doing a fucking telethon right now.
Uh,
let's get to the questions for the week.
I got a,
I got one here.
Um,
am I the only one who thinks Terry Francona is glasses make him look like a
cancer stricken Mrs Claus,
he's the,
uh,
he's the manager of the red sox.
I did see him.
Yeah.
Those days there are definitely a,
he looks like he should be at the very least,
uh,
you know,
going out caroling or something.
Reading the night before Christmas.
I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
You know,
I talked a lot about sports last week and a couple of people really got pissed
just talking about how dumb they are.
Some guys sense this,
this huge fucking rant about saying how,
you know,
being into a sports team is almost as dumb as patriotism.
I know the point you're trying to make.
You know what I mean?
I get it.
You know,
I know what you're saying,
but you know what the fuck dude.
I mean,
I've done like almost two years of these things.
Eventually sports was going to come up that we always have to talk about what
you want to talk about.
This guy was really,
I dunno.
Sometimes I don't know if people are going for Douche bag of the week.
I don't know what do I have anything else here?
I don't think I have anything else.
Oh,
Bill,
I need some advice.
All right,
here's another guy obviously had some Jamison.
Listen to this shit.
This is his question.
Hey Bill,
big fan bombed right now.
I didn't get that for a second.
I thought like he said,
big fan and he meant like that line bomb.
But evidently he means he shit faced or is the worst speller anywhere in the
world.
Here we go.
It starts off.
It says,
anyways,
I need some objective viewpoint.
Me and this hot chick,
I'm a big old ugly rugby player recently started hanging out.
He misspelled that and we like,
no,
he,
he put the e at the beginning of each.
We like each a lot.
Jesus Christ.
Dude recently started hanging out.
We'd like each other a lot.
My problem.
She used to date a black guy.
I have black friends.
My buddies will tear me apart.
Thoughts,
advice.
Thanks John.
Well,
John,
um,
my thoughts are you're pretty fucking shit faced when you,
uh,
when you sent that email,
that's my thoughts cause the rest of it makes no sense.
She used to date a black guy.
Okay.
You have black friends.
Is that supposed to establish that you're not racist?
My buddies will tear me apart
like what?
They're going to in a good natured way rib you that your deck isn't going to be
as big.
I don't know what you're trying to say here.
Tell you what,
why don't you fucking,
you know,
don't email me now cause I know you're feeling the way I'm feeling,
but you know,
sober up.
Try to clean that up.
You know,
I think maybe you got something there.
Send me a second draft.
I Dunno what the fuck that means.
Okay.
She used to date a black guy.
How to fuck would they know
you have black friends?
My Body will tell you where your black friends.
Do they know this guy?
Yeah.
Did she use to date one of the,
one of your friends who's black?
That's just a weird statement.
I have black friends.
Do you have black friends?
Sure.
We all do.
Like you're trying to learn yourself some sort of credit credibility.
The fuck does that make anyways?
You know,
how many friends do I have?
Joe Derosa,
he's half a Gypson so that takes care of the,
uh,
does that take care of Arabs?
Are Egyptians considered air?
I know what the fuck Arabs are.
I don't even know.
I don't fucking know.
I can't,
I know,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
Is being an innocent one question I've always is being Jewish,
is that,
oh,
I know.
It's a religion.
Is it a,
is it a race?
Yeah.
It's not a race.
Right?
I don't want to tie,
a long time ago,
I,
I was in high school and one of my friends was Jewish.
Right?
Okay.
And uh,
I said to him,
I said,
what are you,
Italian?
He goes,
no,
I'm Jewish.
Yeah.
And I,
I could tell I offended him.
So I didn't do a followup question,
but in my head I'm going,
okay,
Italian is a race.
I thought Jewish was a religion.
I know Jewish is a religion.
You know that that would make any fucking sense.
I don't fucking know.
Let's,
let's read a revenge story.
Let's read a revenge story and let's fucking wrap up this podcast.
This is going to be a shorter one.
This is the hangover version.
Oh,
here's something else I came up with is I am actually contributing underrated.
You know it's underrated free Internet in the hotels.
God Damn.
And I liked that,
that wrote all that other shit in anger,
so let's not read that.
All right,
here's him.
Here's a big long revenge story to end the podcast this week and let me know.
Got what you guys think about this sign.
I know I've kind of been turned in my head a little bit and I got this Mike like
stationaries that affecting the sound cause God knows I'm not going to go back
and listen to all this shit.
I usually listen to them but not this week,
man.
Not this week.
It's been up for a fucking week and on with to tell you,
you know,
it's one of these times,
so it's great.
I don't have a kid,
you know,
because I would have no patience for them.
I know it's a new bit I've been working on in my act,
talking about how much I like,
uh,
I like kids when they're,
I like kids the same way.
Like I like dogs.
I like,
I like them when they're puppies and then full of life,
you know?
And once they get a little bit older and stubborn,
they think they know shit.
It's just,
it's fucking,
there are knowing,
you know,
I like kids like,
uh,
your fucking cracks me up.
I saw this kid the other day,
this kid was like two years old,
right.
You know,
it's funny about toddlers,
right?
How they did,
I talked about this already,
how they got their little fucking,
they go,
they already have a beer belly and they never even drank.
They look,
you know,
look,
these little fucking truckers,
it always is just fucking makes me toddlers fucking beer bellies just fucking
make me laugh every time I say,
oh,
you know,
it's because they're not self conscious about their bodies.
They don't give a fuck.
So they just got it hanging out there like some fucking drunken slob at a
barbecue.
You know,
they just,
it's just funny to me.
They look like they've already fell.
They fucked up in life.
You know,
like they're gambling,
they're eating the wrong food.
I don't know.
Why do they have those fat bellies?
Jesus Christ.
You're eating mush in milk.
You'd the of the first,
I don't know.
Why don't I just admit I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about sometimes
and literally sweating right now because of a lamp.
That's how fucking hung over.
I am.
Okay.
Here we go.
You know something,
I'll say,
hey,
I met,
this is something I've been doing.
I've been,
I've been trying to eat,
you know,
one just veggie meal a day,
to then I can make up for the fucking oxen.
Then I'm going to eat later on that night.
Or evidently the fucking steak and shake that I'm going to eat.
And uh,
you know,
I can't stand about those fucking veggie meals.
I ordered this Veggie meal,
right?
I ordered a,
uh,
some sort of fucking horrific Veggie,
a wrap,
which really sucked because they grilled the vegetables.
You know,
like when you go beyond where they stopped becoming mushy.
[inaudible] uh,
I can't even say what it sounds like.
What it,
what it tasted like because it's gonna make me fucking gag here,
but you know,
it just,
I'm going to do it.
You know what?
If you're squeamish,
cover your fucking ears right now.
You know what it tastes like when,
when they over steam vegetables or they fucking,
um,
over grill.
I don't know what it gets.
All squishy and mushy.
It tastes like it's preached,
chewed.
Just pausing right now,
waiting for the groans.
People thrown their headphones off.
All you people on elliptical,
talented.
You just grown.
Do they have the fat Harry Fuck next to you.
Start looking at you wondering what you're listening to.
Um,
this is what I hate.
You're Veggie wrap.
All right.
And they go one veggie wrap.
I ordered some soup,
like an old fucking Jewish man in Manhattan,
right?
And then what happens?
They bring it to me and this,
they got French fries on the side.
It's like,
can't you see?
I'm trying,
I'm trying to get in shape.
I understand it's a French fries or potato.
It's a,
it's a vegetable.
I get it.
What the fuck?
It's like when you go to the cheesecake factory,
you order a salad and then they go,
would you like to third?
It's like,
do you not get the fucking theme here lady?
Did you not see what I'm trying to do?
Do you see my bloated alcohol infused phase two?
You understand what I'm trying to do here?
Actually,
you know,
it's not even fair cause I actually talked to one of those,
uh,
cheesecake.
I think I was making fun of the cheesecake factory and now my act and um,
they're actually was,
there was a waitress in the crowd as always.
I always end up shitting on something and then someone from the crowd is like,
Hey,
I do that.
What the fuck?
So it was this cheesecake factory waitress and she came up to me and she said,
uh,
she goes,
actually,
they make us do that.
We have to do that.
If we don't do it,
we get fired.
Really?
Is that what it's come down to?
That that's where the decisions in your life led you?
That you have a job that if you don't ask people for cake,
which is usually a nice fucking thing to do.
If you don't do it,
you get fired.
They have a gun to your fucking head to basically have your job,
to try to make people become diabetics.
Is that what's going on?
Is that what happened in your life because you sucked at something in school?
You know?
I don't fucking know.
All right,
let's get on with a revenge story.
I am fucking,
I know why I shut off the air conditioners.
Anybody else just hate air conditioning.
I don't mind air conditioning when it's 9,000 degrees out,
but when it's fucking,
you know,
it's like,
I don't know what it is.
It's like 65 degrees out,
70 72 and they got the air conditioning on.
It's like,
are you trying to give me pneumonia?
Huh?
Is that what the fuck you're trying to do?
Jesus Christ.
Am I in a mood?
Hey,
what do you guys think about that?
Swine flu?
You know,
this might be a little comfort,
controversial,
but I'm kind of all for it.
I think this is another time where where were getting in the way of nature
running it's course nature is trying to kill off us.
Not all of us,
but some of us,
so that you know,
there's no traffic.
You know what I mean?
It's like the forest fire.
It's a rebirth.
You know,
you burn it down.
Some animals die,
some trees die.
You get rid of all the brush.
It's like a spring cleaning.
That's all a plague is.
It's just that we,
you know,
you don't want any loved ones to die
plagues and I'll tell you about plagues that there are really,
uh,
they're fascinating.
Like they're,
they're putting out all these stats.
You know what?
Fuck this revenge story.
Let me go on the Internet here.
Let me,
let me,
uh,
let me restart Firefox.
Now.
What is your fucking problem?
I never stopped it.
I'm in the middle of a podcast.
Yeah.
Got Damn.
These fucking computers.
What do they do?
This shit to me.
Come on,
let's go.
Anyways.
Yeah,
they were,
they were given up all,
all these,
uh,
all these statistics on a plagues and that type of stuff.
Evidently.
Do you need all the,
like,
like 675,000 people died in the United States in 1918 because of like an eye
influenza,
whatever the fuck that is.
I ain't know what the fuck that is,
but everybody got it and a whole bunch of people died
and you know what's,
fuck it.
You know what's fucked up about that was thank God they did.
You know,
cause if they didn't,
they all would've fucked
and they would have made more fucking people.
We might've been where we're at right now.
We might've been that,
you know,
15 years earlier.
I love,
I'd just throw numbers out,
man.
Like I'm a fucking scientist here or when I'm talking about,
hang on a second,
let's look up plagues.
It's going to get me on some sort of FBI list.
You know,
I need to do now is Google fucking anthrax?
There'll be a knock at my door.
And I really will be confessing at this fucking table here.
Great plagues
and history.
Okay.
That should be a great game show.
That's,
that'd be a fucking great game show.
Okay.
Is you tried it.
You start googling shit and whoever gets the FBI to come to your place first
wins and you can't do like easy shit like,
uh,
like he obviously any sort of creepy pedophile stuff cause that's just fucking
horrific and it's,
it's never funny is it?
Even though I joke about it on stage sometime.
All right.
List of historical plagues.
Let's go to Wikipedia.
God knows they're always number one.
All right.
In human history,
the term plague refers to an epidemic disease causing a rate of mortality,
a pestilence and academic.
Daesh.
Shut the fuck up.
I want to,
I want stats.
Okay,
what do I gotta go to?
Mlb,
you got to go to CBS sports.com so I got to go.
Ongoing danger.
Great plagues of Athens.
Let's get to some recent ones here.
You know,
what do we got here?
Great plague of Iceland.
See what I'm saying?
Everywhere everybody had a plague in it.
Then the herd,
great plague of Portugal,
great plague of Russia,
great plague of Ireland,
Scotland,
London plague,
just attack the fucking city for two years,
1592 to 1594.
The Italian plague,
everybody's fucking had one was the last time we had a plague.
You know,
you just say that
you just can nip it in the butt with,
with,
with fucking,
with the media.
They just,
they get it out there before it gets a chance to,
to,
to help with the traffic.
You know.
So I'm in New York City right now and they,
if they have a number of a number of cases out in Queens and uh,
you know,
the telling people how,
what's funny as hell,
they tell people that you use common sense.
If you feel like you get in the flu,
go to the hospital,
right?
So they,
they say,
you know,
if you sneeze or if you cough,
just cover your mouth.
Right?
So half hour later,
I'm walking down the street,
walking down whatever fucking avenue here in New York,
and I see this kid on a bicycle and he proceeds to sneeze.
And he just turns his head and it looked like a fucking spit take.
And I just burst out laughing,
bursting out,
laughing,
you know,
rather than being,
I'm like the exact opposite of a,
uh,
I was going to say a hemophiliac.
That's not what I'm trying to say.
What are those fucking people that always nervous that they got something,
a hysterectomy?
What does it,
I know it begins with an h.
This always happens to me is what happens to my fucking brain as I knew the
word.
And then my brain panics and all I'm left with is a letter,
uh,
fucking hemophilia.
I can't get that word out of my head,
you know?
And I got to talk about something else.
Let's talk about the Jonas brothers comedy show.
Huh?
I think I speak for the group when I say it's about time,
you know,
because their music is fucking hilarious.
And,
uh,
I,
I just,
you know,
fucking cons
is fucking business,
you know what I mean?
Really?
Is that,
is that what I should,
that's not what I should've done.
I should've gotten this business with fucking
three,
three of my other brothers.
You know,
I'll play the drums.
You get a Ukulele and then you do this and then you'll get your own fucking
sketch show
sons of bitches.
Oh yeah,
I'm better.
I'm better about the fucking Jonas brothers.
I want some goddamn stats here on dead people.
All right?
I don't feel good.
So I gonna read about dead people.
Make all the black death.
Here we go.
The black death was one of the deadliest pandemics.
The fuck is a pandemic is an epidemic in a pandemic.
A pandemic is an epidemic of infectious disease that spreads through pop
populations across their large region.
For instance,
a continent or even worldwide.
Thank you,
Wikipedia.
So what the fuck is an epidemic
is what happens and you just start fucking search and everything and then you
figure out what the hell
an epidemic occurs when new cases of a certain disease occur in a given human
population during a given period.
Isn't it the same fucking thing?
Is that not the same fucking thing?
I close enough.
All right.
You guys want to hear about the black death,
Huh?
When you're sitting there and your cubicle at work,
while God damn and I'm going to read you some shit.
God knows you can do this yourself.
It's right there.
And Wikipedia.
The black death was according to chronicles,
characterized by Boobos,
a swelling in the lymph nodes.
I don't even know where the lymph nodes are.
I think there are they in your neck a hypochondriac.
Bam.
I got it.
All right.
See,
that's what I gotta do.
Just start talking about all this shit.
Then I don't know where I yell out the word and now I can't remember what I was
talking about.
Oh,
I know.
I'm the exact opposite of a hypochondriac where,
ah,
now that doesn't make sense.
HYPOCHONDRIAC is nervous.
I had to keep my,
I eat apples.
Scientists and historians at the beginning of the 20th century assume that the
black death was an outbreak of the same disease caused by the bacterium who
gives a fuck and spread by fleas with the help of of animals like the black rat.
However,
this view has recently been,
gave me some stats for Christ's sake.
How many fucking people died?
What?
Wait,
wait a minute.
The origins of the plagues does that,
did that to Deb.
Deep Debit to the total number of deaths worldwide is estimated at 75 million
people,
approximately 25 to 50 million of which occurred in Europe.
The black death is estimated to have killed 30% to 60% of Europe's population.
Just stick about that people.
Six out of 10 automobiles that you'll see in front of you tonight as you try and
drive home would not fucking be there.
And we already built the highways.
It's a hole.
You know a ton of fucking car.
You know what I'm saying?
You know it's America,
man.
You want to fucking drive.
Put the top down.
Then I'm making Pontiac's anymore.
How fucking sad is that?
Let's think about some great Pontiac's.
That's where we're going to close out.
After we talked about the epidemic,
we talked about death.
Let's talk about how sad it is that there's no more Pontiac's anymore.
There's just no more.
The Pontiac Trans Am,
Huh?
Got It.
Drops off after that,
but you know,
yeah.
The Sun Bird,
the t 1000 you guys remember the Pontiac t 1000 as when you're really fucked up.
When you bought a bootleg Chevette.
That's when you really were saying that you were an extra level of white trash.
Okay.
You ate macaroni and cheese five times a fucking week,
you know?
Okay.
You know,
I can't even,
what the Fuck I've even said today did I?
Was I riffing about Sharon?
A tray,
a macaroni cheese with another man looking into his eyes.
Okay.
Was that this podcast,
was that another podcast?
Was that at some point a show last night?
I don't know why,
but this has been the Monday morning podcast for a April fucking 20 something.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know.
This is,
we're in the garbage time.
They still have their as well.
They were official site is still up.
What I want to Pontiacs do they have the Bonneville?
You know what?
They were a one trick pony.
Yeah.
Anybody drive a Pontiac?
I don't know,
but let's talk about that next week.
Okay.
This is the Monday morning podcast,
be Caroline's this week.
And then I'm taking a break here for a May and June.
Going to recharge my fucking batteries and I'm coming out swinging in July.
I started the comedy works in Denver,
and then I go do a eddies fist fuck in a fucking a Uma.
I'm just gonna make up shit now.
And then I'm going to be at a wallpaper.
Freddy's at the limelight.
Um,
beautiful theater.
We're a
Cirque de Solei performed just reading awful brochures here.
What is Cirque de Solei?
I really impressed with it the,
the strength that those guys have,
not so much on the costumes.
All right,
you guys,
that's the podcast for this week.
I hope you guys all have a tremendous week.
And I apologize if I was a little bit grumpy this week,
but,
uh,
you know,
I'm sorry.
All right,
that's on me.
I'm just gonna Pause.
I'm sorry.
[inaudible].